neil mac row et vladimir poutine se sont
entretenus par téléphone selon le
service de presse du kremlin notre
correspondant à moscou en trunk
l'hérault revient sur cette conversation
il a bien entendu est avant tout était
question du coronavirus les deux chefs
d'état ont échangé leurs points de vue
et retours d'expérience sur les mesures
prises en russie et en france pour d'une
part lutter contre cette pandémie et
d'autre part minimiser son impact sur
l'économie tout comme son premier
ministre un peu plus tôt dans la semaine
le président français a également
remercié les autorités russes pour leur
aide ou pour rapatriement des
ressortissants français mais aussi pour
leur coopération concernant les vols de
fret de matériel médical et de
médicaments qui transitent par le
territoire russe
d'une façon générale ils ont fait part
de leur détermination à renforcer la
coopération bilatérale et de continuer
sur la dynamique enclenchée en 2019 qui
a vu l'invitation de la dir kutina
brégançon au mois d'août ou encore le
sommet au format normandie sur l'ukraine
au mois de décembre
paris le sujet du conflit en ukraine qui
a par ailleurs été évoqué entre les deux
hommes enfin ils ont discuté de la
possibilité d'organiser un sommet en
visioconférence des cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu un format de rencontre qui avait
été proposé en début d'année par
vladimir poutine